good morning I'm Jeff from the overwatch
team very excited to be here with an
awesome developer update because we are
introducing the 24th hero to overwatch
today so we're here to talk about IRISA
ERISA is a brand new character a lot of
you probably haven't heard of her before
but she has a really cool backstory so
we want to talk a little bit about that
and introduce you to how IRISA came to
be so I'm going to back way up to the
amna crisis which as many of you know
was this terrible world war that
happened where robots sort of took over
the world humans fought back overwatch
was a big part of that we eventually
struck peace with the aam necks but
during that amna crisis there were many
different on Nick units used in the
battles so as you know Bastion as
example was one of those units that was
used in the battle well there was
another unit called the Oro 14 which was
specifically a unit designed to fight
against the humans and be part of the
amna crisis well fast forward many years
later after the omnitrices peace has
been struck were in the city of NIMH
Bonnie where humans and objects get
along great it's actually one of the
most technologically advanced and
peaceful cities on the planet but they
start to start to run into some strife
from a local villain who you might have
heard of before his name is doom fist
and in order to start to guard against
doom fassett act and protect the city
against any other dangers that that
might come about the citizens of NIMH
Bonnie developed a more advanced version
of the old Oh r14 unit which they not
surprisingly called the o.r 15 so it was
one version higher well the Oh ar-15s
initially were ok and suited for battle
but they eventually lost horrific Lee
against to Memphis specifically in a
battle that took place in the NIMH bond
Airport and most of the citizens of NIMH
Bonnie just gave up on the ar-15 said
you know they failed miserably they're
laying in pieces scattered throughout
the airport terminal this is no good you
know we give up on these things well
there was a young girl who didn't give
up hope her name was effets she was
extremely smart girl excellent at
science robotics mathematics programming
she still had hope she still believed in
what these lo are 15 units were supposed
to do for her city so she sort of as a
scrappy young girl took the pieces back
to her workshop worked on this unit and
created the evolution to what the o.r 14
and 15 s were and named it IRISA and she
made a single heroic unit that wasn't
supposed to be part of a huge battalion
but was supposed to be a specific
individual hero and named it IRISA so
IRISA in terms of the timeline of
overwatch is a brand new hero just on
the scene so we have yet to see what
ERISA is really going to do so that's
part of what's very exciting most of our
our heroes have a big historical
background we've seen them succeed and
fail in their past histories where ERISA
is new on the scene and it is effets who
has created her who is really
encouraging her to become a new hero of
the future now let's talk about
mechanically what ERISA does and what
she brings to the game and why we
designed ERISA the way we did so let's
talk about her abilities first first of
all she's a tank so she will be in the
tank roll her primary weapon is called
the fusion driver it's think of it as a
projectile base machine gun she moves a
little bit more slowly when she's
shooting it but it has a good range to
it probably more range than almost any
of our tanks have on their weapons
maybes areas alternate fire goes you
know equally far but she's got a good
range on it good rate of fire
are really high sustained weapon with a
large clip size so that's a fusion
driver the alternate fire ability on the
fusion driver is of extreme utility so
it sends out basically a pulse think of
saria's graviton charge which is re is
ultimate but it sends out a single pulse
out from her and then you can click your
alternate fire again and it will bring
any affected targets within its radius
for a very short period of time so it's
like a little mini graviton surge that
she can do more often and mostly she's
using it for positioning or
repositioning her targets it also you
know briefly puts them in place so if
you have a teammate who's a Widowmaker
or Hanzo or even erisa with her great
range on her gun can shoot towards that
and it really helps you line up some
critical shots that can happen you can
also pull people around corners with it
so that's a really fun ability that she
has she also has a tank ability called
fortify and what fortify does is it it
not only makes IRISA a little bit
tougher but it prevents IRISA from
sustaining any sort of crowd control
ability that might be used against her
so like the most obvious examples are
maybe ferry's concussive blasts which
normally knocks people around you know
moves them out of position if IRISA has
fortify on and she's going over that
bridge in the gardens of lijiang tower
you can't knock her off at that point
she's she's in place plus she doesn't
take as much damage as well so fortify
is a very useful very straightforward
tank ability now one of erisa most
defining abilities is her protective
barrier the protective barrier is you
know think along the lines of
Reinhardt's barrier shield or Winston's
barrier bubble that he throws out the
protective barrier has quite a range to
it's roughly the size and shape of about
half of Winston's bubble and it goes out
anywhere where she targets it so it
could be in front of her could be
slightly off to the side she could use
it in clothes on herself or she could
use it you know further in front of her
to shield an ally and it creates a
barrier that has the normal amount of
damage it can take like other barriers
in the game you can destroy it things
that go through barriers like symetra
Salter net fire will go through this so
it's got a lot of utility to it and a
lot of use and a lot of protectiveness
and lastly there's her ultimate ability
which is her supercharger so she wears
this drum like item on her back when her
Ultimates up she can take it off her
back throw it down on the ground and
it's effectively damage boosting anybody
who's in line of sight of the
supercharger now the thing about the
supercharger is is that the enemy team
can kill the supercharger so you really
need to make sure to protect your
supercharger either with your protective
barrier or maybe you want to put the
supercharger you know just off to the
side out of line of sight of your
enemies but in line of sight of your
teammates so there's some gameplay there
to figuring out where the supercharger
is because if the enemy team kills it
right away then your team loses all of
that benefit now with ERISA I really
want to talk about why are we adding
another tank because I know that topic
will come up and a lot of people are
sort of wondering you know how do we
pick what heroes come next and there's a
lot of reasons for that but primarily
with ERISA we were looking at our tank
lineup and you know we have heroes like
diva and Winston who are much more
disruptive in terms of tanking they're
much more defined by their mobility they
like to get in they like to get out they
don't stay in one place for too long
they cause a lot of disruption and
harassment you've got somebody like like
road hog who
he's all about punishing people who are
out of position and positioning himself
to punish people who are out of position
so you know he plays a very different
sort of role but we were spending a lot
of time looking at Reinhart and saying
what really defines Reinhart and why is
he so important critical to overwatch
and we started to describe Reinhart the
term that we would use on the
development team was we call him an
anchor tank and what we mean by that is
that the Reinhardt almost anchors the
entire team the team it with a properly
positioned Reinhardt the team builds and
positions around Reinhardt because he
doesn't have a lot of mobility abilities
and because he has that protective
barrier in front of him you sort of know
where to position yourself and when the
team is going to engage or disengage
based upon what Reinhardt is doing so we
like this idea of what we kept calling
an anchor tank and we felt like players
needed more options in that sort of
anchor tank role we wanted another tank
that teams could build around and
position around and even though we think
that tanks like Winston and diva are
really great in what they bring to the
game they're not necessarily bringing
what Reinhardt was bringing so we hope
that in ERISA there is now another
option to a low mobility tank but one
that brings a high amount of protection
in her protective barrier where you kind
of see her on the battlefield and go
okay we're approaching from from this
angle I will get behind erisa I'll
follow IRISA she'll put the barrier up
we'll follow her in and we'll engage in
that regard so we know that there are
concerns about barriers in the game
we've actually you know we've been
working on Bastion retuning him to be
more effective against barriers we do
have some very effective heroes against
barriers right now for example symetra
with her alternate fire goes directly
through them obviously Reinhardt's fire
strike goes through barriers as well
jump trots grenades do tremendous damage
to barriers and will melt them very
quickly and if barriers become
much of a thing we're looking at those
in terms of balance and and how to
adjust accordingly most of all we just
wanted to bring a new and exciting hero
to overwatch not only does she fill a
role that we felt was very needed not
just a tank but one of these anchor
tanks that you really build it a team
around we also felt like ERISA was
visually challenging we often hear that
you know when it comes to female
characters they tend to be more limited
in their size and appearance where the
male characters get these really like
big and challenging visual designs that
are very exciting and we've heard a lot
of desire to have a very visually
challenging female character so that was
fun for us to explore as well so we
really wanted to bring that to overwatch
and most of all we wanted to bring a
really cool hero with a lot of backstory
that really rounded out our current cast
that is not only these old-school heroes
who took part in the old overwatch and
talent and amna cattles of the past but
really brought something new and gave us
some new hope to look forward to what
are the heroes of the future going to
bring to overwatch so we're really
looking forward to all the feedback
we're going to get on ERISA we're going
to keep working on her until she's just
right and just perfect we hope you enjoy
her and thank you very much we'll see
you soon
[Music]
you
[Music]